I'm enough the first new rules everybody
knew all right you know someone has to
explain to the man on a flight from
Scotland to Amsterdam who tried to open
the planes exit door at 30,000 feet
because he thought it was the door to
the restroom that that's the kind of
stoner move you make on the way back
from a new rule don't leave a brother
Hank
new rule Google's Nels new self-driving
car has to emasculate us a little less I
mean I want to tune out while getting
there safely too but not like a little
bit I mean look at this thing it's like
a Volkswagen Beetle at a Mentos had a
baby honestly the only way this car
makes sense is if I'm chasing jewel
thieves through Paris in 1992 while it
makes this noise
new rule the man at a Michigan gas
station who lit his car on fire when he
tried to kill a spider on his gas tank
of a cigarette lighter has to assure us
he's not the same guy who thought the
exit door on the plane was the rest new
rule coming out of a blackout with no
memory of getting a tattoo is it really
appointment television
it's what alcoholics do but if you like
watching blind spot
you'll love wet spot about getting up at
4:00 a.m. and pissing in the hamper
you